nos dicen que hdx es igual a 3x gente es
igual a menos 2 t - 2 - hdt fn es igual
a menos 5 en el cuadrado más hdn así que
tenemos tres definiciones de funciones y
dos de estas funciones de hecho están
definidas en términos de otra función en
particular de hdx y nos preguntan cuál
es el valor de hd g de 8 esto podría
parecer bastante complicado pero lo que
tienen que hacer es recordar que todo lo
que es una función es algo que toma una
entrada y nos da una salida y este
enunciado que se ve bastante complejo es
una forma de decir que vamos a tomar el
número 8 el número 8 y va a ser la
entrada de la función g
la dibujamos como un cuadrito g y esto
va a producir nuestra salida de 8
y después vamos a tomar cualquiera que
sea el valor resultado como la entrada
de la función h
así que tomamos todo esto como entrada
y lo que nos dará es la función h deje
de 8 que fue nuestra entrada de 8 h deje
de 8 vamos a hacer esto un paso a la vez
primero encontremos cuál es el valor de
g de ocho g8 y voy a usar aquí el código
de colores para que visualmente sea más
comprensible g de 8 es igual a bueno
aquí tenemos la definición de gmt y en
donde sea que veamos una t lo vamos a
reemplazar por nuestra entrada que es 8
va a ser menos 2 por 8 reemplazamos este
con nuestra entrada que es 8 - 2 - y
bueno esto parecería un poco complicado
vamos a reemplazar este con el 8 y
veamos si podemos encontrarle algún
sentido vamos a ponerlos en el color
correcto menos 2
- h de 8 noten que es para evaluar gene
8 lo único que hice fue en cualquier
lugar que me encontré una t la reemplace
por un 8 ahora veamos si podemos
calcular esto esto va a ser igual a
menos 2 por 8 va a ser igual a menos 16
menos 2 va a ser igual a menos 18 usemos
el color correcto esto va a ser igual a
menos 18 menos hd 8
pero aquí es igual h de 8 vamos a hacer
esto en esta parte de acá h de 8 y esto
de acá ahora veamos la definición de h
no se preocupen ahorita todo esto más
adelante lo vamos a poner como entrada
de la función h pero ahorita vamos a
preocuparnos nada más por este paso así
que h de 8 pues en cualquier lugar que
encontremos una equis la vamos a
reemplazar por un 8 así que va a ser
igual a 3 por 8 es igual a 24 así que
este valor de aquí es un 24 y como lo
estamos restando a un valor negativo
menos 18 menos 24 pues va a ser igual a
menos 42 usemos un color adecuado menos
42 ya encontramos cuál es el valor de g
de 8 es menos 42 esto de aquí es igual a
menos 42 y ahora podemos tomar como
entrada este menos 42 en la función h
vamos a escribirlo por acá hd menos 42
recordemos que en menos 42 es lo mismo
que g de 8 así que hd g de 8 es lo mismo
que hd menos 42 y esto va a ser igual
vamos a usar de nuevo el color que
corresponde
menos 42 menos 42 que nos da
menos
126 y con eso terminamos parece complejo
al principio pero si lo vemos paso a
paso es bastante sencillo de resolverlas
simplemente hay que tener muy claro cuál
es la entrada y cuál es la salida y así
evaluar estas funciones debe ser
razonablemente directo